oui merci jean pierre comme tu l'as dit
le président de notre mouvement a
souhaité régulièrement interrogé les
adhérents de notre famille sur
l'élaboration du projet j'ai l'honneur
de le conduire sous la direction d'eric
woerth on travaille énormément fait
beaucoup travaillé les conseillers
nationaux et bien évidemment vous êtes
les premiers que l'on appelle à nous
dire ce que vous en pensez vous savez
qu'on a eu une première réunion de
travail sur l'immigration vous aviez été
53000 à voter sur les questions qui vous
avait été posée à l'issue de cette
réunion de travail
une réunion sur le code du travail vous
aviez là aussi a répondu présent avec 42
mille adhérents qui avaient répondu et
sur la sécurité la justice était cette
semaine c'était mardi dernier vous avez
été plus de 40 4044 1118 exactement à
répondre au questionnaire alors un grand
merci à vous je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que vous pouvez régulièrement participé
à l'élaboration de notre projet vous
pouvez aller sur le site internet de
l'est républicain point fr et vous
pouvez déposer vos contributions très
régulièrement sur une vingtaine de
thématiques on en fait notre miel avec
eric pour élaborer le projet des
républicains sans plus attendre non qui
avait une douzaine de questions la
première question numéro 1
doit-on libérer les policiers et
gendarmes des contraintes
administratives qui pèsent sur eux afin
qu'ils puissent se recentrer sur leur
métier dans la lutte contre la
délinquance vous avez été 96 points 53%
à répondre oui
question numéro 2 faut-il étendre les
compétences des policiers municipaux
pour en faire de véritables partenaires
de sécurité aux côtés des policiers et
les gendarmes là encore à 86 06 oui
question numéro 3 l'armement des polices
municipales dans une ville de plus de
10000 habitants doit-il être de droit
sauf opposition du conseil municipal
87,26 % 2
question numéro 4 à l'exemple des
interdits de stade
faut-il permettre aux maires d'interdire
temporairement à des individus fauteurs
de trouble de paraître dans certains
lieux pour des motifs de prévention à la
tranquillité publique 94 8% de oui
question numéro 4 êtes vous favorable à
une nouvelle législation sur la
présomption de légitime défense des
policiers et gendarmes dans l' usage de
leurs armes afin de sécuriser leurs
interventions
oui à 90 59%
question numéro 6 soutenez-vous la
construction de plus de 20000 places de
prison que madame taubira bien
évidemment à supprimer supplémentaire
pour adapter notre système carcéral à la
réalité de la délinquance
oui à 95 points 43%
question numéro 7 faut-il mettre fin à
l'aménagement systématique des courtes
peines de prison cent mille
condamnations qui ne sont pas exécutées
dans notre pays chaque année on l'a
rappelé mardi
ainsi qu'à tous les mécanismes de
réductions automatiques de peine pour
redonner tout son sens à la sanction
oui à 89 95 % question numéro 8 les
peines planchers instaurée par nicolas
sarkozy abrogée en 2014 pour la
gouvernements doivent elles être remises
en place pour les récidivistes et les
réitérant oui à 97,50 question numéro 9
l'administration pénitentiaire et les
douanes doivent-elles être rattachée au
ministère de l'intérieur un grand
ministère de l'intérieur pour améliorer
le pilotage des forces de sécurité y
compris en prison oui à 89 46 % question
numéro 10 faut-il élargir le champ de la
rétention de sûreté aux terroristes
sortant de prison pour permettre la
surveillance et l'isolément dans des
centres de déradicalisation à l'issue de
leur peine en fonction de leur
dangerosité
oui à 97,28 % question numéro 11
devant la multiplication des campements
illégaux faut-il donner davantage de
pouvoirs à l'état pour les faire évacuer
en urgence et rétablir
dreux républicain et ainsi montrer une
véritable autorité oui à 96,31 %
question numéro 12
faut-il refonte de la justice des
mineurs autour d'un code pénal
spécifique en marquant une véritable
césure entre la justice de la famille et
des enfants et la justice pénale des
mineurs pour redonner tout son sens à la
sanction
oui à 93 0 4%
je crois que c'était la dernière
un grand merci pour votre participation
sachez que les deux prochaines réunions
de travail seront consacrés la première
le 18 novembre à l'agriculture et à la
ruralité là aussi on fera des
propositions et la voici vous serez
amené à vous exprimer
et la deuxième avant noël ce sera sur la
fonction publique ce sera le 25 novembre
et là aussi vous pourrez donner votre
avis comme le président nicolas sarkozy
s'y était engagé
merci à vous